sex and procreation are two different
things right but when somebody has sex
when somebody's life into the world
exactly when somebody has sex they're
risking procreation so the two are
obviously intertwined
I think the whole framing is so sad I
know you're saying that chase because
it's like that's the way people think
today is oh I'm gonna have sex and risk
procreation when creating a new human
life is so amazing not if you don't have
resources not if you don't have money
the thing is the thing is people people
don't think about the fact that they're
risking procreation no that's why we're
in the situation that's true but also
what if people chose not to have sex
until they were in a relationship
publicly with someone they were
committed to for life and prepared to
have children that might come from that
we'd have a lot less murdered babies
love this totally love this wonderful
appearance this is the base jab right
hook Chase is there with the bass jab
jab jab yeah when people have sex they
risk procreation Lila comes in and she
says it's not a risk it's an opportunity